oh is it live as soon as this is live
yep
hello and welcome to the new rockstars
office chatter uh this is a little a
little peek behind the curtain here at
new rockstars as we gather around the
digital water cooler to talk all things
spider-man no way home you know this is
the kind of conversation that we
normally have in the office every monday
uh but this office is closed for the
holidays we thought we'd just meet up
virtually because this is the future
we're living in the future baby isn't it
beautiful uh i'm off-screen producer
brandon and here in the office chatter
today we've got philip you may have
heard of him before uh we also have
editor john
we've got off-screen producer zach
we've got our researcher whitney
and we also have editor riley
uh and we also got editor josh who's
watching what you say in the comments uh
and and keeping a close eye on you guys
but he might jump in you never know he
loves to to pop into the office chatter
every now and then shout out to the
shiny shack uh thanks for the super chat
uh we're very happy to receive those and
also to receive all of these people
joining us uh many of them are just
focused on josh
yeah say nice things to josh she's got
to read your words so be kind to josh
yeah we're so excited to have you all uh
join in to hang out with us and hear us
chat about spiderman no way home we'll
we'll of course be having lots of
spoilers here so i hope you've seen the
film if you haven't uh i hope us
spoiling it for you is as enjoyable as
seeing it for the first time no don't
why don't talk what i don't want them to
leave if you haven't seen the movie
go
away yeah dude
immediately better
yeah yeah that's right
what this is free yeah yeah uh we're
gonna we we wrote down most of the
script as we could remember it and we're
gonna do a live read right here oh god
that there's a reason this is free
please go see spider-man
please please
i've always wanted philip to break up
with me while our teenage son makes out
with his girlfriend in the other room
yeah uh well i'm sorry i i'm not doing
that live on stream i will kiss someone
upside down
before the stream is over
and so far that person is cody brant
with 9.99 highest
exactly
toby
rightly their super chat it means that
we will pronounce their name properly
it's kobe not cody wow um
well maybe if kobe had donated ten
dollars
way to debut on the channel editor riley
as the uh the jerk who's roasting our
favorite super chatter our second
favorite
we have two super chatters they're both
our favorite
it's true um so like i said normally on
mondays you know we all we're in the
office we're good friends we get along
uh don't believe what the press says we
have a great time in the office
yeah and we we usually chat about the
the content we consume over the weekend
and you know for the last nine weeks
that's been succession i mean what a
show check it out uh but thankfully the
movie we've been waiting for all year
long has finally arrived spider-man no
way home um so let's get into it guys
and if you guys have questions out there
throw them in the chat uh pr uh editor
josh is watching that chat if you got
questions of your own somebody just
already said something that is
mind-blowing in the chat just so you
know we are watching the chat uh also so
you know we are some of those comments
are getting filtered you guys
objectified everyone immediately uh but
somebody just said something crazy
uh they said what if it doesn't matter
uh that she died because aunt may is a
scroll
um
confirmed that she's not a scroll
because when she died her face didn't
transform oh right yeah we didn't see
her all the way die she acted very still
yeah classic squirrel technique that's
exactly and then slinked away
by the rules of on-screen death though i
don't know
we could take a page out of mt's book
who thinks this was all
[ __ ] and perhaps mysterio wanted
everyone to think now all the drones all
the drones were taken by the government
i love mtv
i hated that theory
i love you very much but legitimately i
was like i swear to god if mtv mtv
if mtv comes back uh enough mt's theory
is real i will quit
quit watching whatever they quit living
well okay so we've broken the aunt mail
see aunt may seal what do you all think
about the uncle benning of aunt may in
this film i will say my wife was
devastated uh and there was a lot of
audible sobbing in the audience and my
wife still hasn't forgiven kevin feige
for what he's done but what do we think
about this uh you know this kind of redo
of the classic uncle ben uh death that
pushes peter to be a better spiderman
[Music]
i
like it because we had this weird thing
where we all assumed that all this like
formative stuff in peter's life happened
before
uh anything that we'd seen and so it's
pretty lame to like just like not have
such an essential moment that's like
crucial in you know peter parker
actually becoming spider-man it's
actually very interesting to realize he
didn't know that before well he like did
the head nod thing but like that this is
now the moment where he's actually
earned it that it it actually is an
interesting thing where it's like wow so
what version of peter do we get moving
forward uh
i don't know i'm very into that i'm very
confused because my screen just shows
two zacks
i also see two zacks
this is a classic star trek episode when
picard's turning into a borg i see two
zacks
that was that was just a that was just a
multi-verse zack showing yeah
in this multiverse we have two uh
zacks instead of two peter parkers zach
is so boring that he's exactly the same
person in every multiverse he's exactly
how dare you you're like that you
mispronounced kobe's name aren't you
right
yeah
zach could be so perfect that there are
no needs for variants
stay on topic guys uh the uncle benning
of aunt may if you will you know yeah to
your point phillip i i do think it's
interesting to see it after we've come
to know these characters sorry to step
on your words john i didn't realize
you're talking yet uh but you know a lot
of superhero movies the first in the
series has some kind of death and it's
been done well it's been done poorly but
like i thought it was more effective in
this movie because we really came to
know
aunt may and you know peter over the
course of three films
well not may is such an anchor point for
peter where
yeah he loses uncle ben but he has on me
for most of his life like this is i mean
he literally has no one john you were
talking i i swung right in i'm like is
that zach do you have anything you want
to add
no so what did you start talking about
my points
one of the things that we found really
refreshing about this this group of
we didn't have to do the origin story
again we kind of know spider-man's
backstory we can just kind of get him
doing the things that we love to see
spider-man do
it's the third of the trilogy we get the
famous line from aunt may instead of
uncle ben we get to see spider-man you
know make his own suit at the end of the
movie
webb slinging through new york they talk
about the spider bite i love that we get
a lot of those classic you know peter
parker moments finally this film
it was like catharsis almost for a lot
of the movie and we got
we would have been tired of if we had
seen them you know five years ago when
that first movie came out and and now oh
they hit they hit yeah
you didn't answer the question do you
like the anime is now a dead
and i man that zach was a scroll
yeah
that confirmed um just wait till you
watch me die um well i was gonna say
like one thing this particular the tom
holland version of peter parker right
like i guess two movies in a row he's
been mourning at least the second half
of this movie he's morning right last
the last movie from homie's morning tony
stark during the whole movie right if
anything tony stark was his uncle ben
uh in that movie because in homecoming
he we didn't see a lot of sad morning uh
ptsd
peter right like that's not really a
part of this particular version of peter
so like interesting they set this up
whatever whatever solo apartment having
peter in the future is going to be you
know the next time we see tom holland's
peter parker it seems like
it
then he's going to be kind of the peter
parker we're used to from like the toby
films right like with this chip on the
shoulder of the the person close to him
that he lost
yeah hey real quick we got a a sweet all
super chat we got a couple super chats
we're going to try to keep up with them
as they come in uh but ismail montoya uh
killed my father but also
uh he says hey guys seems that wong was
handed the title sorcerer supreme who's
in charge of handing out that title like
who's the source of supreme's boss or is
there a council of sorcerers maybe that
is it like the pope where they blow
smoke into each other's mouth
that's how vaping works not how pope is
um kids don't pope dude
vape now that's that's how this is
um i think chris angel hands out the
title
i believe legitimately though how do you
guys think that they like determine that
as soon as he comes up and he just goes
are you ready and like that's how you
become sorcerer supreme
there must be like in camartage right
there must be a council of elders some
kind of thing
right like wong was in charge of the
book somebody else must be in charge of
the ranks
you know it seems like tilda swinton
just comes back it's the sorcerer's job
now it's the sorcerers who's closest in
proximity to
the sorcerer supreme is when they die
tilda swinton is dead there's stephen
strange see the train is dead there was
wang it's just a proximity game how to
glue yourself to the santa claus rules
got calvin
santa claus yes scott calvin rolls all
the way yeah
we have a similar rule in place at new
rockstars which is why i spend so much
time around phillip uh just waiting
waiting for him joke's on you i'll uh
outlive all of you um but uh by design
that's how i hired you and uh
each of you terminal in your own way
you'll see um speaking of uh uh terminal
in their their own way eric boss is
alive do not worry uh he just got a
little bit more suspicious
eric works through the weekend really
hard and this is also a chance we wanted
you guys to see a little bit of what
it's like to work in new rochers now
everybody real quick you can go around
uh what are your your holiday plans
because we're
i'm the only one in office today
uh uh are you guys all
zach i know that you're in kansas kansas
representing central time zone here uh
staying with some family uh
throw uh throw a k in the chat no don't
do that
no do not do not throw a bunch of caves
in the chat
yeah that's a bad idea
um i'll be staying in los angeles so uh
you can't try and break into my
apartment um but i have some family here
who i'm excited to safely see on the
holidays
uh that'll be very nice i'm driving up
to sacramento tomorrow
so please do break into my house and
leave goodies that's what i would water
those that's what santa does yes until
you kill them and become santa
and whitney aren't you also going to
yeah i'm uh i'm driving up to
snowy mammoth mountain california
my parents live up there and i'm gonna
visit them uh i'm driving up tomorrow so
it's really cool because philip asked me
to do this live stream and i was like
yes because this means that i get to
miss the part where my parents forced me
to drive with them to reno to pick up my
brother at the airport and i'm like oh
hell yeah i don't have to do that part
now so now i'm just gonna drive up
tomorrow it's gonna be chill but yeah
it's it's uh there's apparently been
like a huge snow storm up there so it's
gonna be uh powder city bro nice uh
whitney uh you need to know we did we
did coordinate with the van landing hams
and uh you're gonna pick up your brother
tomorrow i'm sorry
[ __ ] you
oh sorry
[Music]
[Laughter]
i'll really quickly shout out those of
you that uh uh
have heard my stories on this channel
you know that i i have a lot of drama
with my family and so i am uh
uh just delaying for as long as possible
before i go back to miami i think i'm
gonna make an airport stop away from the
window
all right let's go again guys just take
it right back why do you think i don't
want to be stuck in a car with them
driving to freaking reno yeah no i'm not
interested yeah gross reno and my
family's
interesting all right look uh let's get
back on some uh super chat uh david
miles uh it says hello from scotland who
has the best scottish uh accent here
john do you gotta be zach i think you
should give it a give it a whirl phillip
go for it okay
brandon i feel like you have a good
scottish accent uh let's see
yeah what's your culture i'm a huge fan
of new rock stars so what do you think
of andrew garfield versus tomahaddi
venom potentially an amazing spider-man
3 movie oh i've gone i've done it
very good favorite spoiler man is andrew
who's yours
okay
not enough screeching for me but uh
uh not bad uh real quick i'm gonna say
did anybody else i kind of respond to
this question here did anybody else go
like holy crap andrew garfield's
spider-man is the best
like it's so good oh a hundred percent
because i have been like locked in this
argument with uh one of my best friends
his name's john and uh we have been
locked in this argument because i love
toby peter he loves andrew peter and oh
different john sorry
my apologies john you can also be my
best friend if you want i thought you
were too late
he thought it wasn't i'm so sorry i'm so
sorry
uh the argument that i always have about
andrew garfield's uh amazing spidermans
is that he's too cool to be spiderman
he is like a hottie he is skateboarding
he like dunks on
the the the jerks in the school
basketball auditorium place yeah like
he's way too cool to be spider-man i
would never pick on him ever i would
like immediately be in love with him and
in my opinion that's not
who peter parker is to me
but in no way home andrew garfield
became the perfect peter parker and he
was the absolute best peter parker and i
have a completely different opinion
about him now i think that's him i think
what you're definitely nailing that
happened now was that his like giddiness
and his jokiness and all that it came
from a place of uh like anxiety and
insecurity that felt right right where
it's like those of us that joke because
we are scared of being judged for who we
are you know for the rest of our merit
yeah
but
to answer david's question i think like
he's the perfect guy to fight venom
because as we found out he's touched the
darkness right he's gone to that dark
place and re-watching those amazing
amazing spider-mans yeah he's cool and
he skateboards but i think that's okay
because man they put him through some
real tragedy in those two i'm not saying
it's not okay i'm just saying he's cool
and that's not a bad thing it's just how
i would describe it who who would be
better like who would be a more
effective fighter against tom hardy's
venom andrew garfield's uh spider-man or
tom holland spider-man
probably i think andrew garfield andrew
garfield has to do it because he's the
only one out of the three of them who's
never fought an alien it's his turn
that's a good idea oh good point no he's
unprepared
though i mean scared but like so were
they at all
i want i want tom holland in any fight
only because he doesn't have as many
arthroscopic issues as these older
beaten up spiderman you know
problems
that can be fixed though they have like
cbd cream now
that's right i'll be fine
barkley's on that lower back well we're
talking i mean andrew garfield is not a
very old man but toby looked good didn't
he i'm surprised he really did he's also
pleasantly surprised
but he is in the
i don't want to say the word posse
because i don't want to get kicked off
the internet or whatever but you know
the
the he's in the posse and with with the
dicaprio gentlemen and i yeah they have
to be they are they're obviously like
siphoning youth from a vampire and
they're siphoning like from all the hot
women like all the hot younger women
that they date i think that they are
both siphoning the youth he looked i i
don't know how much of the suits were
obviously a lot of the suits in in
motion when they're flying around is cgi
but like he looked trim in the like when
he's just wearing the suit standing next
to garfield or holland uh he looked good
you can find it on youtube but um when
sam raimi was trying to convince the
studio sony to let uh
toby be spider-man they weren't
convinced that he could pull it off he
did like a screen test fight scene where
toby maguire's shirtless like fighting
like bruce lee and he is very trim and
very fit uh and we said that's on
youtube brandon he said i can look at
that right now yeah you can look it up
on youtube
i've got to take a pee break y'all uh
okay
yikes uh but yeah he was he was looking
very trim uh a very capable fight they
all looked great uh also it really shut
off how tall andrew garfield is as yeah
oh my god him crouching yeah
you say that about everyone
[Laughter]
oh god as the matumbo i do i do want to
point out that uh another super chat
came through from vinceres who uh said
that it'd be a good side fight but what
about andrew garfield and tom hardy
teaming up in a lethal protectors movie
because that's kind of what they'd have
to do right that tom hardy venom is is
not like it'd be weird if he was like
i'll i'll kill spider-man that's it
i mean that is still weird about the
venom movies where it's like venom is a
bad guy because he eats people which is
that right you know everyone should have
their day in court you don't deserve to
get eaten uh for robbing a store um but
he's also he there's always a more evil
thing that he has to fight so he's
ostensibly our protagonist in these
movies well if he goes full venom and
goes after spider-man tries to eat him
is he no longer likable we want him
fighting along spider-man yes also i
will say so right we see in the
post-credits scene the little bit of
goop gets left on the mexican bar tom
hardy gets zapped back to his normal
universe we we suspect so that part of
the symbiote is gonna attach to somebody
else so there'll be a non-tom hardy
venom somewhere in the tom holland
universe
well i i know that venom hates hates all
spider-men so it's it's less eddie
brock's responsibility to keep him from
eating people and more so than
having this inert
innate urge to just
everyone that was red
bull
fireman yeah
uh
wait i i that is like the thing that one
of my big lingering questions as i
walked out was you know after that post
credit scene of the goo
uh it was like okay so are we going to
get a whole new venom and a lot of
people are feeling like that would be a
perfect thing for flash thompson
i am i'm not into that do you think that
yeah goop will try and find the mcu's
eddie brock and just be like listen i
know
you're you're a home for me in my
universe or where i came from so i want
to be in you here
hey
could they they could still cast tom
hardy as that eddie brock right because
some variants look the same
in different multiverses
i do think that just from a casting
perspective the actor playing flash
thompson it's
hard to buy him as like
venom tom hardy menacing you know shots
fired at tony revolori
yeah that's right i'll say it
tony river lori someone who i took a
picture with because i was excited to
meet him and i looked so bad in that
picture that i've never shared it with
anyone
in the chat let's see that pic philip
you know who they should cast chat is
going to get phillip to put his twitter
uh and get the upside down kiss you make
it an nfd they should cast for uh venom
would be do you guys know who logan
marshall green is
yeah
zach is the only one that knows uh i
have no idea he's in the floor he's just
this other actor that just looks exactly
like tom hardy's never mind
google yeah john you don't know what the
hell you're talking about
yeah
he's in the florida the kid for
moonlight right
yeah looks exactly like tom hardy
because i'm coming back
if you guys are if you if you guys are
just coming in uh to our live stream
here this is the new rockstars office
chatter where some of the behind the
scenes folks at new rock stars mostly
philip who's the most behind the scenes
is we can push him down uh and we're
just chatting about spiderman no way
home lots of spoilers having a good time
reminiscing about a great weekend of
cinema
oh i scared phillip away
so sorry phillip uh he had to hit oh he
was trying to finish his gallon of water
um there's lots of speaking of the chat
lots of questions about venom tom hardy
whatever i think people are very
intrigued by that first push credit
scene
yeah well it was kind of like when we
got a
ways through the movie and it was like
okay i don't think we're going to see
venom in this movie
but when they did start talking about
fighting alien symbiotes i was like oh
he could show up for this last fight uh
but it has grace venom
yeah yeah that would be even better to
have toe for back
great question from
john likes how much you could see his
face with the little things stuck to it
in the breakdown
it is good and and i will say the venom
symbiote like crawling in uh spider-man
3 looks great still it still looks
really good uh well it was real it was
practical it was practical they got
alien symbiote
they got goo
okay
another super
another super chat we had uh from jake
he got jake on on youtube that's a tough
one to get uh what side would toby and
andrew spidey be uh in the classic civil
war starker cap and we'll stick to the
mcu i think we should stick to him we
know what happens
so easy but i'll take this argument so
you guys have to come up with your own
uh
definitely
toby is like by the book following the
rules and he's like i signed the sokovia
accords first you know and uh
yeah and andrew garfield would so be
down to like go underground and just
like be a little too cool for it oh no
hell yeah yeah especially broken andrew
garfield who said he was not pulling
punches anymore right
smashing yeah yeah he would have killed
someone at leipzig he would he would
have just killed killed someone just
quickly while we're on that subject uh
so everybody else kind of like got fixed
right like they fixed doc ock they've
mixed everyone
the only person that they like didn't
fix was andrew garfield and i'm just
like baby i can fix him
we fixed andrew garfield peter parker
he's going through a dark time he lost
gwen but it's like whitney's here
whitney's all right it's okay in a way
mj kind of fixed him right by falling
off that scaffolding and allowing him to
save him
that point though where so tom holland
is just like smashing willem dafoe's
face in and uh you can see andrew
garfield in the background going like
yeah do it
do it
do it
um what else we got here we got the bag
man asked uh will the future mcu venom
symbiote still be voiced by tom hardy i
feel like that'd be so funny like no
matter the person no matter who the
actor is leave
tom heidi as the voice
it felt to me like it was their way of
saying like we we love venom we want him
to be a part of our universe but like
here's the like sony marvel line that
we're we're kind of drawing um or the at
least the existing venom the existing
mcu line that we're drawing so i would
imagine a new voice actor but
and and to me
i i know they leave that little bit of
goo there
i feel like that scene
yeah as we all do when we go to bars um
uh i feel like that push credit scene
was actually not a tease of more things
to come i think it might have even been
a wrap-up right of a story that started
in the post-credits scene of let there
be carnage it ends right there because i
don't think the sony films the spider
films want to be burdened with this kind
of crossing of streams i think this
movie was the end that gave us all the
crossing of streams we could possibly
ever ask for and now it's done okay was
anybody else a little bit let down when
he just disappears at the end there and
it's just like oh never mind
yeah i i would have i would have liked
to see more he interacted with zero
characters that we're familiar familiar
with he went from his mexico to our
mexico
yeah
i liked grant brandon yeah but like that
maybe
brandon had a theory that lizard and all
of the trailers
they were just like covering him with
different cgi for the trailer so i
thought they would like just put enough
platelets
so fun that would it wouldn't have
ended up telling but oh man yeah i would
have loved to see that that'd be great
uh i i wish they did do a decent number
of changes uh you know like the doctor
strange wink was not in the movies i i
noticed that and i don't know and i
don't think one said like don't do it
yeah
yeah yeah
and then he said [ __ ] instead of crap
scooby do this [ __ ]
espresso 13 year olds and above
um okay we got another super chat here
uh ivan morales asked uh thoughts on
electro mentioning a black spider-man
does miles morales appear in the next
spider-man movie i mean they've been i
mean he's he's your brother ivan i think
you should i know
and i feel like tom holland in the press
you know
amy pascal was very quick to be like oh
there's gonna be three more spider-mans
with tom don't worry and tom has been
saying weird things like oh i don't know
where it's gonna go i'd love to be a
producer on the film because that's
something i've never done and i think
like this could be the transition like
we saw on the spider-man like video game
where he meets a miles who also
you know it could be i don't know if
miles will even come from a different
universe or a multiverse they'll be in
the mcu already and we'll just have like
two spider-mans in the mcu now without
an oscorp where are these spiders coming
from i don't even know but
uh
i think we'll definitely see miles
within the next three spidermans i don't
see how you don't do it wait that's a
huge question
sorry i i will come back to it brandon
just made me think of a huge question
should i have kids no never mind
no
no i shouldn't no no i'll come back i'll
come back to it uh john go and do what
you were gonna say i just think that the
in the reality of the
there was a miles morales from into the
spider verse walking around right
and you know we saw with the preview for
multiverse of madrid
multiverse of madness that characters
from what if are potentially crossing
into
uh the mcu in live action so
there's certain
morales walking around during the events
of no way home
we saw neither of them and i'm guessing
it's just marvel's not ready to cast
that character yet but
yeah they're around i blame ned ned was
calling peter parker's
she wasn't calling miles morales or
spider-man you know interesting what's
up ned yeah uh okay you guys ready for
my big question that brandon just
brought up oh this is this is now an
episode of big questions
okay are you guys ready this is huge
okay
in spider-man homecoming or even before
that tom holland spider-man whitney can
you hear
are you me you're not you're not leaning
in with your eyes okay okay all right in
tom holland's spider-man's universe if
there's no oz corp
where did that radioactive spider come
from
[Music]
the zoo next question
um i think they could you know they
could do rocks roxanne right maybe
they could do aim maybe but uh
that's like it's gotta be something
cooler it's gotta be something cooler i
mean if it's one of those weird spiders
almost like uh the one we saw and into
the spider verse that maybe can
change uh whatever multiverse it's been
if it's some sort of interdimensional
spider
crossing through that came into the mcu
i feel like i have the answer i have the
answer we all know what the answer is
stark that's that's
the iron spider was radioactive and bit
him
when he was a little kid
in the iron man costume
and then tony was like [ __ ] i gotta take
care of this kid now i got 18 years
yeah it's just tony's guilt that i mean
it could be it even if it's even if it's
unknown or or happy's guilt that forged
his weird trauma bond with uh aunt may
but definitely like could be like a
ninja turtles ask you know some stardust
yeah
just stark ooze uh like baby batter
after all what is peter parker if not a
teenage mutant ninja spiders but uh
who's persevering
[Laughter]
uh guys i think that we just blew it
wide open somebody had a good theory uh
dkmtg says the spider came from the
government trying to recreate the super
soldier serum
that's pretty solid there's a lot of
like similarities the government is
using my tax dollars to make super
spiders
i'm changing
spiders no that's not officers are
powerful enough i would love my tax
dollars to go to culture like that
brandon hasn't paid taxes in a decade
i'm a free citizen okay
i'm i'm not i'm traveling on these roads
okay
uh we got to do more super chats we
can't talk about my my tax status uh
well we can and we will but no don't
tell the government uh kobe bryant asks
do you
uh do you think it's still possible to
see uh
uh an mcu born norman osborne and harry
osborne that was one of my questions
where are harry and norman in this
universe i had i'm going to jump in
right away i thought that maybe the
norman we get in this universe rather
than being older than peter is going to
be a contemporary of peter like a young
norman osborne
not one who's set up the company but one
who is like growing the company what's
still in his garage right now that would
be king joffrey style child norman oh
interesting just a 12 year old running a
huge company and then harry potter's
like i gotta kill this kid yeah what
about harry osborne he's a little
paranoid
right yeah yeah yeah
he could be his pet hedgehog it's fine i
mean it makes a lot of sense like with
what they've done with mj of like
doesn't even her name is
is not even mary jane right like he just
kind of has similar initials like they
could really play fast and loose with
the character of norman osborne right
like it could be uh
um i want to say norma osborne
could be norma schnosborne i think it
would be a fun origin story for if if
they were a contemporary of peter for
peter be like i've dealt with
a norman osborn yeah
i have to work with you and and peter's
like absolutely [ __ ] not absolutely
and that would be like really fun and he
pushes them to become the villain
right now
that's a great argument for why maybe
the osborne's will not show up even
though i thought that that's going to be
the key to the next trilogy which
supposedly they're doing uh you actually
are making me feel like no if he's
already aware like wait your last name
is osborne even if it's schnozborn
i think he might you know pick up on
that um but so then let's go back to the
idea of it was a very funny joke but
could it be real that ned is being
pushed to become
definitely a sorcerer of some sort but a
villain
i think i think he'd be a great fighter
he's the next sorcerer's supreme
closest to him we decided that santa
claus rules state that
we all know santa claus rules
i think it's especially interesting
because wait
yeah what's going on in ned's head right
now he doesn't remember that his best
friend in fact he doesn't remember his
best friend right like really doesn't
has no connection with him to spider-man
probably in love with mj by the way who
wouldn't be yeah
but he still knows he still knows magic
right so in his brain how did he learn
magic
yeah well he doesn't have the sling ring
he didn't learn it he just was good he
has enough natural talent he could be an
x-men you know
anyone could do this exactly i do think
that brings up a good question though
which is like all these people who have
forgotten peter parker how much of their
lives that peter was involved with do
they remember because you know
potentially ned is still aware that he
did that but also there's a universe in
which just like anything tangentially
related to peter parker is stripped out
that's a big that's a big question uh so
real quick one more time for those just
joining us
we are the new rockstars back office we
do these casual conversations uh instead
of doing our work all the time the video
comes out late it's because we were
talking about
yeah this kind of stuff and we just want
to show you guys a little bit of what
it's like uh to to work at new rock
stars is these stupid geeky
conversations but uh yeah let's get into
that right the idea that it takes to
remove peter parker from everyone's
memory how does that have ripple effects
i think the most easy way to jump right
into a specific moment is
do ned and mj even remember being on the
statue of liberty were they just like
what am i doing here why am i why do i
have a vested stake in this yes they do
remember it they're probably just like i
don't know why i was there all i know is
that spider-man saved me but not peter
parker you know yeah but like yeah the
why they were there yeah i would even
make an argument of liberty
i want to say two things one oh we got
eric voss in the chat by the way whoa
you guys let me out of the dungeon this
guy cannot take a vacation
i wanna i wanna say two things one
peter parker in this movie is the lori
laughlin of the mcu this dude did all
this stuff to get his friends into a
good school okay that is college
admission scandal 2021 okay
two
um
like
you could make an argument that both mj
and ned's lives are now worse
for not having remembered peter right
how much of ned's self-esteem and
self-worth was from being the guy in the
chair from being tangential to the this
awesome superhero and mj that was her
first love so now has she's still not in
her brain she's never known love at this
point she's never known love no no not
the love of the parents
[Laughter]
we don't see them for very long at the
end of the film but just the way they
both behave in the donut shop
they don't feel like ned and mj from the
first uh spider-man movie in this modern
trilogy right like they just even in the
way she interacts with peter at the cash
register she seems very self-possessed
confident
uh yeah yeah that too
i mean brandon and mt mentioned
this on uh
the episode of inside marvel which was
like okay a couple people have died if
they were to
would they still
remember peter parker in that yeah does
the ghost of tony stark know does the
ghost of aunt may not i was wondering
that's a very interesting question again
i think the answer is probably i think
you guys said yes but i think the answer
is no because magic
i don't know
also you don't believe in god uh
that's a big
what god would allow all this to happen
in the mcu oh god when you got a thor
real quick uh some shout outs uh from
super chat uh thanks eddie for the shout
out to us but uh dmx factor has a really
interesting question that uh they well
i'll spin it in a direction they're
saying they'd be interested in seeing
mcu heroes turn into the venom versions
of themselves but that actually is like
a bigger idea than it sounds like the
goo is in the mcu
we could now
yes uh an mcgu hero
could get the goo
it doesn't just have to be an eddie
brock right it could be a doctor strange
it could be uh a you know a miles
morales maybe that's actually yeah
and imagine
what if getting his hands on the goo and
ingesting a little bit of that power
into him maybe we'll see a little bit of
that and multiple little symbiote stuff
well and now we have the you know that
as mt pointed out like the ebony blade
is related to
no
which created the goo and we're gonna
have gore the god butcher and thor four
more four so like it does seem like the
symbiote is there to be more than just a
venom it is a bigger story and in the
comics the goo's been on a lot of things
groot had the goo at some point uh
rockets at the goo there's been goo on
lots of people
i want to see
i want to see bruce banner
i want to see bruce banner hulk and
venom in the same body that's what i
want
oh just fighting for
jose rodriguez asked how exactly do you
think the leftover venom will obtain his
spider abilities man people they're
they're already on defending now
and do you think it can transfer to the
venomverse i do think that like this is
how the venom and the venomverse will
get
to be like more of like a spider the
venom in the mcu will interact with
spider-man and through its you know
multiverse hive mind share the info with
tom hardy who will be drunk and one day
start just swinging around
also did tom hardy know they were
filming
honestly no he was just asking honest
questions catch me up on the mcu real
quick yeah he's like i i only picked him
i got to be on five minutes what do you
got
that did feel like a weird break from
his character like dude is a journalist
and he's like i need to hear it for a
13th time what is
going on
with my tom hardy impression i'm tom
hardy what is going on a terrible
scottish accent
you're just joining us super chat uh
mark garcon uh when do you think mutants
will start to play out in the middle of
all this i feel like i may have been
seen a few when reality started to crack
in the final battle no way home uh i
wonder which ones they're they're
thinking but definitely i mean mutants
now are in such like a weird thing of
the category because if you think of
like wiccan for instance and these
characters that have already been
introduced in scarlet witch it's like
maybe the term mutant first of all maybe
they'll be like that's kind of a hate
word guys let's
just not call people freaking mutants
but yeah there's powered people in
different ways or do you guys think
they're gonna let out be like and now
mutants
the longer they go without introducing
it the more i worry about how it's gonna
happen i you know i do think it could be
something with like the scarlet witch
just being doing a reverse you know no
more mutants and being like lots of
mutants please um but
i i think it's better if like they've
always been there but
i was hoping that something would
activate their powers like if the blip
had like activated all these powers but
i i don't know how they're going to do
it now my guess is that we saw at the
end of the eternals
this uh celestial
kerashem was like okay
i can see if these humans are really
worth saving my guess is he'll be
in the comics the celestials created the
the mutants and human in humanity and
the eternals if he comes back and says
here's the condition you
run the show on earth anymore we're
giving you mutants that's how this is
going to work
i think maybe that's how we can
as like a foil to all the heroes they
already have it's like we're introducing
movies
yeah
i yeah i don't know how they're gonna do
it uh let's see another super chat chris
campbell asks i want to see flash on a
sad vacation to mexico and then have him
make it
and then having it make its way to him
so like flash goes to mexico because
flashpoint has been wiped out of
existence and he's depressed so he goes
on a trip to mexico and that's how he
gets uh uh the the goo on him down there
in mexico
do you think that works do you like that
idea
i don't think flash goes to mexico i
think he goes to a secret rich person
island for vacations
i mean maybe it's like the first 15
minutes of um
of contagion the movie right where it's
like it's the the goo is hopping from
person to person until eventually it
gets to the
you know i don't think we're ready
eventually it gets to gwyneth paltrow
and she's the new venom and she coughs
all over flash and she doesn't remember
being in the movie at all
um
louis felipe asks do you guys think wong
will die in strange two they're gonna
kill the sorcerer's supreme again yeah
well mordo wants all the sorcerers dead
and so who who to go after but
i wouldn't make him the sorcerer supreme
if he's next to wong when wong dies
and then he has to kill himself
oh that is the ultimate that's how it
has to end right now you got to turn
that on yourself
we call that mordo imordo you know what
i mean
i'm
do not care for that brother i think i
think the correct answer is post more
dome
oh okay that's a that's a good sub
subtitle for the movie
yeah i don't i don't want juan to die
he's got to have one of the highest q
ratings in the mcu oh yeah you love it
every time that guy shows up that's true
he's doing well he's not right he's that
right level of character though where
you can kill him you know what i mean
and it's sad i mean
but we talk about this a lot when we're
talking about secret invasion which is
like he's the perfect candidate for a
scroll right he is the exact level of
character where you're like if that
dude's a scroll it wouldn't be the most
surprising thing ever and it would be
pretty impactful he's a scroll confirmed
i couldn't find john's lack today
uh another super chat asked about
miles morales this is from d smurf uh d
smurf uh do you think if they're if we
do get a live action miles morales movie
do you think he'll meet our newly
forgotten tom holland spiderman or maybe
cameo as like
uh miles's roommate what if the the two
spidermans they room up together which
would be convenient it would be a smart
thing to do
so if you're green goblin you just have
to bomb one apartment and you get both
fighters
that's probably not smart
i i don't think anybody should have
roommates in general
just wow she's coming down hard on
roommates the cost of living is high
folk i don't know what you expect people
to do
i share too many bedrooms in my life i'm
over it
oh no same yeah i'm very very over it
mostly i'm thinking of peter's actual
apartment it's like
god and imagine they're both trying to
hide their identities from each other
too
yeah and also you like you guys realize
that that apartment probably cost like
33 000. yeah that's a yeah
300 a month like that's at least like a
3 300 a month studio in new york so
that kid is paying a lot of money for
that really don't live in new york why
does it come with a stained mattress
first of all i have never rented an
apartment that comes with a mattress
extra that is you got a picture for that
it's true yeah and then
and then it's also pre-stay wait i i ha
i'm not kidding i have rented an
apartment that came with a mattress
really yeah
it's how is that mattress
has never given me a free mattress i
have had to schlep mine from from county
to county my whole
yeah i got existence mattress very well
another super chat
fire flame 62. uh seeing that
daredevil's in the mcu do you think that
they will introduce the time displaced
fits from agents of shield since the
main fits died i mean this is asks a
bigger question about like if they're
dipping their toe into bringing in the
netflix stuff and we don't know how much
of that they're gonna bring in are they
finally gonna canonize agents of shield
uh which they put lady siff in
uh but they refuse to acknowledge its
existence in the mcu do you think
they're opening up to that now now that
we've seen some netflix pull over i i
think only if it serves the films right
like that's why they pull in matt
murdock gear devil because it's really
fun to see him and it makes sense we
don't you know we need a lawyer let's
use him but like
only if it's gonna be really fun and
propulsive for a plot of one of these
movies don't you think that they would
ever like pull in something from agents
of shield
yeah i do
it's hard i agree
nice agents of shield right it started
as canon we had tie-ins with the movies
and the movie characters and now to kind
of say
oh you know how it happened i don't
think they can come back and say okay no
we were wrong it's it's it's canon again
let's uh let's blast through some other
uh super chats real quick uh first of
all shout out to black loki a big fan of
his and he of ours uh
did aunt may die just be because peter
didn't make a phone call
yes
what which phone call the phone call to
ask like to get his friends a second
chance into oh yeah yeah
it's like it's like he literally
couldn't do this
again
and that's why all of this happened i
mean anyone that died any on that bridge
yeah i thought you were asking if you
should have called 9-1-1 faster lazy to
make a phone call yes all right hot take
uh whitney uh i mean i will also say i
heart agree with this person those
police officers shot at spider-man in
that lobby not knowing who else was
right they opened fire
yeah little stray bullet could have
killed me i'm not saying it happened but
they know he's a high school student
yeah they know him yeah now they know
he's like a teenage boy
jeez yikes but mysterio was a big fan of
the police union so
that's true man i loved hannibal burris
you killed mysterio
moving on
i remember peter opened the box with the
ged test in it peter parker no one
remembers he has no public records he
has no school records yeah eric pointed
that out uh that was missable 56 i
believe there you go yeah uh duet troll
says how would you guys save spider-man
if you were forced to canonize the
venomverse movies over the next trilogy
morbius trailer seems convoluted as f
hm
well to be fair the movie may not be as
convoluted as the trailer might appear
yeah you never know but that was true
but who is the spider-man who is the
spider-man in the venomverse that's my
question i mean just make it make it
andrew and that way you get your
andrew andrew garfield one yeah that
just solves his dream to fight an alien
and he's going to be happy and sweet
yeah
bring him let him back in let him back
in uh chris
m3 chris campbell says uh imagine
finding out that peter's parents are
secretly still alive and now they don't
remember him
they're both just like do you feel
better about yourself today i don't know
what it
is yeah yeah
i don't feel guilty anymore yeah
uh marianna kliss
as said just a random reminder that
killmonger and zola are still fighting
over the infinity stones and we're in a
pocket damage
anytime you're feeling down out there
just remember zola and killmonger are
still fighting
irrigated
into that box
so yeah somewhere by the the washing
machine in the sub-basement of the
sanctum cemeterium uh a.d has a good
question about what is going to happen
with matt murdock now because it's like
well we're not going to give him more
seasons of of the show
right and also like
kingpin is other people's problem
currently so does matt murdock just like
only practice law now is that well i i i
will say maybe two opportunities that
make a ton of sense we do have one more
episode of hawkeye it would be pretty
dope if he did show up in the finale of
hawkeye that would be pretty cool or
i mean we have all we have she-hulk
coming right down the pipe a fellow
you know marvel lawyer
you know if she's ever like you know
pairing up with the co-defendant
yeah ugh
that's so boring to me sorry that was
good fashion lawyer fun yeah this is
gonna be it's gonna be like legally
blonde but instead it's matt murdock i
just i i just daredevil is awesome matt
murdock is kind of boring to me like the
law and order special gamma unit okay
um john wanted to point out that ned
likely studied or like
that likely nerd studied magic since he
knew know the name of the underground
sanctum santorum workshop the undercroft
uh so maybe he's been studying a little
magical outside he's just reading enough
and sleeping into that smart brain he's
mit worthy no but also
every kid like of all the like you know
you can't fly or whatever but it's like
maybe i can maybe i have magic for
instance like when you
make people you know have you guys done
this you guys know this but do you do
this everybody do this real quick
i am slowly with my mind going to bring
your fingers slowly closer together
it it's in it see see no oh john stop
spreading them this is the power of
suggestion
uh okay smart asses uh whitney's the
only one that stays working that's herod
look when you're just like trying to
believe that you are magic so of course
ned would be like look i'm not i don't
know how to become a superhero but maybe
i can learn
magic um
we could all learn magic folks uh chris
toscanzo toscano asked uh or he's
pointing out we were talking about
morbius right here's what he saw in the
morbius trailer okay you have the toby
slash remy spidey graffiti that looked
like the toby spider-man we saw on the
poster you have the daily bugle logo uh
of course uh you have um the amazing
spider-man 2 oz corb logo i don't know
the validity of that statement but he's
claiming that this is the one we see in
auschwitz editor john's agreeing with
that and then we also see mcu vulture uh
uh so what's going on are they mixing
all the universes is this a whole new
universe where a lot of things look the
same uh
i i agree
they're technically this is so
stupidly neat you rockers the the the
graffiti is not from the rainy films
it's from the ps4 game uh and it's the
rainy suits in the ps4 game so they're
really stretching
yeah
that was real nerdy i love that i think
we can all agree that like pick pick a
spider-man pick toby or pick andrew and
just throw him in that universe and have
it make sense somehow that way like
i think inventing a whole new universe
is just so tough
i want to jump real quick to carlos
rivera's question that's just going by
right now if you see it is tom holland
the only peter that's being forgotten
the reason that that is such a crazy
question is does toby mcguire's peter go
back to his world and he's like hi mj
and she's like who the [ __ ] are you
yeah and not only that he's stabbed so
just a a stabbed guy with like a hole
in him walks into your house you never
you never want to meet a stabbed guy
no you don't you're just kind of girl
you meet his dad guy for the first time
who's insisting he's your husband that
is truly the worst case scenario i love
me children if you're following whatever
if you're following the venom rules of
that post
he just phases back into where he was in
reality so he's somewhere
hudson river in new york drowning
because he has a cap shield to stand on
oh yes yeah he's dead
a lot of tragedy he's dead because he
drowned because salt water got into his
one yeah wait peter can't swim do you
get confused
no that's cannon no you ever put a
spider in water they stay on the top of
the toilet
they're fine uh
no but legitimately do you guys think
that that the other peters might have
gotten forgotten
i didn't i think it goes into you then i
assumed that like the like loophole that
they're gonna use is that because peter
was the one who spoke the spell and he
said i want them to forget that i'm
spider-man that
what like that's that's what i assume
they're gonna say yeah
it'll be like for an end game when they
were like when they snapped when he
blipped everyone back or snapped
everyone back they were brought back in
safe ways so like if you were flying in
an airplane when you blipped you didn't
appear back in the sky and then just
fall to your doom if you were in the
middle of surgery when you blipped you
didn't come back with your guts open
spilling out everybody some of those
runes have very clear exceptions
yeah yeah there's there's asterisks on
the runes you gotta slow it down you
have to zoom in and
you can see it all yeah thanks for that
uh super chat carlos rivera uh somebody
also rafiki uh brought up that brad
davis should be venom that actually kind
of works a little more for me than flash
thompson because that guy looks like
hidden
dominating he's a he's a pretty handsome
fella
you think venom has to be handled hands
to be handsome toe for grace
toe for grace most handsome man when i
think of a handsome man
uh money cat says uh why does the lizard
come to tom holland's universe he
admittedly doesn't know peter's identity
uh he didn't know a maiden spider-man 2
said he thought he'd be black uh he
might they might be thinking of electro
um yeah and so there is a theory about
this
and it is that uh
you know the the uh we learned in this
movie that electro has just
gone to the grid become kind of pure
energy that it's possible that he
downloaded basically the internet or
something like in that moment and just
kind of like if there's like data out
there about it uh he might have been
able to put together
that right then but also it just kind of
seemed like yeah let's bring back jamie
foxx yeah
because i also thought that i thought
both of those things where i was like
does mj not remember him and how does
jamie fox know uh but yeah i think i
think it's just
movie logic guess what it's a movie
that's how
and not only that it's a comic book
movie so like
yeah i mean i i do agree like when i
left this film it felt like when i left
endgame where i was like well now i just
have like way more questions and it
didn't answer all of my questions but i
agree this was so great to see uh yes
there was a lot of fan service but man
did i love that fan service uh and you
know it's been decades of
building spider-man movies all to bring
us to this this ultimate fulcrum uh
which i think was great and a great
point a great turning point for the mcu
i'm really excited to see where it goes
from here i've got some uh some big uh
questions for you guys that i want to
blast through
uh
real quick at the end here uh
well maybe here's a simple way to put it
what's everybody's hottest take about
the movie
um
i would say my hottest take this was
what i felt like initially when i was i
when i was in the middle of it and when
the three the three peters land on the
top of the statue of liberty and that
beautiful shot i was like this is so
great to see but we kind of did this
with under the spider versus a little
bit uh you know these these are all
spiderman we know which was which was
nice about it but this like crossover
story you know we did it very well and
into the spider verse so i think this
movie is still great and still holds up
but it
the surprise of seeing all these
spiderman together was like not the same
i think as if this this had been come
before in the spider verse
hot take hot take i take
my hot tank um
i think this movie
was the end game of spider-man movies
right it was it was aiming to be kind of
the culmination not only of these three
films but of a bunch of films before it
i think it struggled a little bit under
the weight of that because this movie
didn't have an infinity war to set it up
right it kind of had to be infinity war
and end game piled into one i think it's
such a fun movie he did such an
excellent job i wouldn't have minded
maybe like the infinity war to
no way oh interesting i mean split this
movie in two yeah hot take not enough
movie
yes
all right all right who's next hot takes
my
uh
doctor strange is still so weird in this
film
don't get him you know
we were like he's acting strange he's
character or is it just because trailer
editing but after watching the film i'm
still like i don't know that
to something so i i don't think that the
mcu will will go there i think he's just
being doctor strange in this movie but i
do think he was like just weird
you think i agree he's still weird i i
don't think he's up
was playing it like he was you know what
i mean i don't think they're gonna do
finding out he lost
he lost the title of sorcerer's supreme
i think he's just pissed off maybe maybe
real quick
spin-off question off of that hot take
that take hot take uh is
is this really what causes the events of
multiverse of madness that it just again
peter didn't call
mit
and now like they rip seams in the
fabric of the universe and now like it's
all destroyed to be fair unzipped the
universe
because because peter didn't want to go
to sunny utica okay uh great school
the the entire world falls it's it's not
peter's fault he didn't call st strange
should have asked him before he popped
off a spell that he was in the middle of
when peter was still talking about to be
that it this is a hundred million
percent dr strange's fault it is nobody
else's fault peter is a child that is a
grown-ass man who should have explained
to him the consequences also who starts
doing an irreversible
like multiversal brainwashing spell
before explaining the basic vibe before
you go into it yeah maybe you should
have been like all right rule number one
you cannot interrupt me rule number two
would you like to make any
specifications
canon cannot remember you number three
have you tried emailing the dean of
admissions dear god like why like ask
any of those questions even one week
and it's like okay but like you you
didn't go through and do the work and
now stuff like this is happening stephen
this is a hot take
it feels hot to me
i think that peter
should have
should not have left mj and ned at the
end of the movie i think he broke his
promise uh and
and i'm developing trust issues about it
like i
i
i think it i don't know yeah i mean
obviously they left it a little bit open
and he could still go and
go back
it felt like something they did from a
filmmaking perspective to let them go
into this next trilogy
and it feels like it betrays a little
bit of peter's character uh to do that
okay i got i got into one of those like
immediate like like fights with my
boyfriend that wasn't a real fight it
was just something that it was a fight
that i made up in my mind because i was
imagining a scenario along with your
boyfriend that you made up in your mind
and uh
i i was like i was like babe if if i
ever forget you
do you promise do you promise that
you'll actually remind me because i was
like if i was standing on a shield in
the middle of the hudson river and i
begged you to please come find me and i
said the words to you i don't want this
like i was like would you would you come
tell me and he was like i don't know
do you have a band-aid on your phone
yeah yeah like you have a band-aid like
no like
just
yeah
a hot take that is actually pretty spicy
and i'm i'm not a hater but remember
this is hot takes if you don't want to
hear anything even remotely negative uh
uh scream at the top of your long set at
home and uh that'll distract you uh i'll
say uh spiderman no way home great movie
loved it so awesome first half just okay
movie
that first hour i was a little
incredibly sarcastic saying that you
oh no
i knew this is down that way but no the
first hour i was like i don't know if
they're gonna pull off the spectacle and
the height of this movie uh second half
of the movie is so good that it like
the average is like still through the
roof but at the beginning i was a little
um not not loving it
sorry go ahead go ahead
we're so nice in the post department
look at us
i wonder phillip if
i'm going
function of our jobs right we over
analyze everything in the trailers and i
felt like i knew the first half of that
movie and i absolutely
and i think if we had maybe not spent so
much time looking at all that footage we
would feel a little differently yeah
well campbell agrees with you too uh in
the chat
uh yeah that's a great point i'm wrong
again
oh like as i was watching the movie and
i was like ticking off trailer shots as
we went by them i was getting happier
and happier at how much
how little of the trailers covered the
second half of the film because when you
watch those trailers you're like there's
a lot going on here it turns out it's
mostly because they do a bunch of like
cgi crazy stuff in a condensed period of
time
uh but yeah it made me more excited to
see that the trailers were getting
burned through do you guys want them to
keep up that thing of the trailers just
being super misleading and like cgi
removing characters from the movies
which version of us are you asking right
because movie going john is like
absolutely don't show us anything but
editor john is like we didn't reach for
this
second breakdown
um
uh movie john that's the one please i
never want to see another trailer again
honestly
all of us would have bought tickets the
second they went on sale if they just
showed us tom holland being like i made
another movie yeah
if that was true we all would have seen
cherry
that's true
they gave it away for free
it's really strange when you see
it's strange when you see interview
footage of tom holland and you hear his
southern accent you know and he's just
like
hey
it's me
speaking of accents david miles has a
challenge for us says that richard
madden uses his scottish accent and
internals uh so you can practice by
listening to him but he wants us to do a
challenge and he claims that whoever
wins this will get a deep-fried kebab
sent to us in the post which i think
will not pass customs also sounds like a
threat
[Music]
that
what that's that's what it it's in this
you can look in our slack
so far i'm the only one that did it i
get that kebabs
congratulations
i don't even think i can and you got two
gallons of water to wash it down with
i'll tell you what
it'll be delicious cowards say that
there it is zach what was that
gonna die that i don't know that sounds
good
and play it in political ads in scotland
uh guys we uh again we yeah somebody
just said exactly the right thing andrew
this feels like a zoom happy hour that's
because this is basically what we do at
the office and we were just playing
around with this uh idea of the people
that are uh destined to be off screen
and uh meant for it uh we we just wanted
to share some of our uh uh opinions uh
but we definitely also i don't know we
want to know if like you guys like these
kind of casual conversations everything
that we do is so
freaking polished and like researched
and written and scripted and eric does
everything uh to like you know this the
a great degree of detail but it also
means that it's very hard for us to just
have casual conversations with any of
you guys so i don't know this has been a
little fun for me but let us know if you
guys like this kind of thing maybe join
us on these kind of calls a little bit
more regularly
you tell us what do you guys think are
you guys enjoying people seeing what
we're like at work yeah i mean like
hanging out with us they're like does
this suck for you
[Laughter]
i'm happy to not be doing my real work
so that's fine yeah fine with me yeah
you're in charge of our paychecks yeah
yeah there'll be no christmas this year
kids
uh and then everybody else uh you'll
offline about it and let me know
i feel like we should hit these last few
super chats i don't think any of them
are comments so there were a question so
we should just cover him real quick
dober squad says i thought loki caused
the issues in the multiverse that's it
that's a rogue theory for you somebody
else had a fun take that they were like
it's all of these things right it
locates all these all these but those
are none of them are the ones that
actually break the multiverse yeah just
some other thing like uh putting a chip
bag in the microwave or something
i would argue that that loki didn't do
anything to the multiverse he just let
it go it was it was being done too
already uh
who remains he let it go free
chris campbell says i'd love after all
these disney plus series and this film
if the reason the multiverse is messed
up is because of something totally
unrelated off screen and i just really
wanted to hit that a second time
kevin williams so the villains have been
saved and returned if they actually do
live in their own universe how do you
think the tva would see that absolutely
right like these are such epic moments
in the history of those universes and
it's like you know what never mind we're
gonna completely change this reality
because you cast a spell like it's all
breaking all of the tba rules however
they might be busy dealing with some
other stuff right now just by chance
that's true and maybe this was always
supposed to happen yeah this was always
this is how aunt may died and he got the
words he's got to get the words uh so
you know it's got to happen
uh
jose oh
jose mari z
said i hope you guys do these more often
in the words of kylo ren
more
was that scottish i don't know
that's a callback if you're just joining
us and omar solman uh who do you think
will be the main villain of spider-man
4. i have a good feeling it'll be
kingpin and we're going to have a spidey
daredevil team up let's go
[Music]
thank you
okay uh you can't take the uh omar's
idea
all of you are just like yes
i take his idea
i claim it i claim his idea
yeah and then give it away if you don't
want somebody to take it huh yeah that's
right uh and chris campbell uh yeah yeah
shouting out uh thank you so much chris
campbell by the way for uh being such a
big part of the conversation it's like
you were here uh with us and you know
instead of john that might have been fun
uh is anyone else happy now that spidey
isn't billionaire funded anymore i'm
gonna think who isn't right like that
said
there is something to be said for the
fact that uh in the comics spider-man is
is such a uh fun character to throw into
team environments and see how he
interacts with everybody else because
despite being a you know superhero
himself he's probably the most like the
rest of us you know that he's just like
out of his element at all times and they
really did a great job of showing that
in things like infinity war uh where
he's just kind of like i can't believe
i'm along for this ride and the movies
had never gotten to show that right he
always had to be the pinnacle of
strength and like wow a superhero to so
i've appreciated the mcu gave us a
version of peter parker that is like the
team team-up stories that are in the
comics because the mcu is much bigger
than just spider-man the way it's uh
been done but yes now that we got that
trilogy out of the way of team ups it
would be nice to have some small you
know black cat relationships and ones
that are more about
uh you know the network of spider people
and staying here
i'm i'm happy to have billionaires out
you know i just think the billionaires
are
well before any uh
anyone else on this team gets
assassinated by the billionaire class we
should probably get out of here before
we offend them anymore the illuminati is
taking us out
thank thank you to everyone who joined
us for this new rockstars office chatter
uh we love talking spider-man no way
home we all we hope you all have a happy
and safe holiday however you you choose
to celebrate it um and maybe we'll be
back someday uh i've been off screen
producer brandon we got editor john we
got uh oscar producer zach huddleston
recently revived editor o'reilly and
researcher whitney and of course the big
boss man himself uh phillip but you guys
have a a great holiday we love you all
yeah thank you guys so much follow us on
twitter if you want to keep chatting yes
add new rockstars yes all right bye
everybody bye